- We're gonna switch gears and talk about
dermatologic issues in
kids with Down Syndrome.
This talk was created together
with Dr. Renee Howard,
one of our professors of
pediatric dermatology at UCSF.
We thought about doing this in tandem,
switching mics, and then we
figured, it might be best
if one of us presented the information,
but she will be presenting next about
dermatological issues in all
individuals with disabilities,
and will be answering questions together,
AKA she'll answer all the
questions about dermatology.
Still nothing to disclose.
We're gonna talk about
common dermatologic issues
in individuals with Down Syndrome,
talk about some treatment modalities,
and then identify which things to refer
and which things to
manage in your own offices
if you're a doctor.
So let's start by talking
about cutaneous features
in children with Down Syndrome.
A variety of dermatologic issues
are more common in Down Syndrome.
The single transverse palmar crease,
please do not call it a simian
crease, that's insulting,
is the most common cutaneous finding.
It's unilateral, but it's also very common
in the general population.
In general, transient
cutaneous manifestations
are more likely to be
seen early on in life,
while the more chronic skin conditions
tend to emerge later on in life.
There's several pre-disposing factors
to having skin stuff.
Number one, I think hypotonia.
When you're a baby, you're more likely
to stay in one position.
So the neck, the armpits,
the inguinal folds
are gonna be chronically
exposed to moisture,
which can lead to rashes.
Lying on your back all the time
can lead to rashes, bald spots,
pressure sores in rare occasions.
The low oral motor tone
often leads to drooling.
Poor coordination with
feeding leads to milk facials,
and food facials which are
not great for the skin,
and then the delayed
achievement of continence
means that someone is gonna be in a diaper
for a longer period of time,
also pre-disposing to rashes.
Premature aging, also pre-disposes
one to skin differences.
Pre mature onset of age dependent changes,
like hair graying and
thinning and wrinkling,
and is thought to be related
to a lower basal level
of DNA repair enzymes.
Especially the decreased ability
to repair UV induced DNA damage,
as well as possibly overproduction
of oxygen free radical.
This peroxide dismutase
gene is on chromosome 21
and oxidative stress has
been linked to T-cell
mediated skin diseases,
from psoriasis to seborrheic dermatitis,
to contact derm and atopic derm.
Immune dysfunction also plays a role.
Individuals with Down Syndrome
all have sort of a
relative immune deficiency,
no unifying diagnosis,
but definitely abnormal.
Antibody mediated and cell
mediated immunity in vitro,
we've seen reduced killing
of Candida albicans
and Staph aureus,
and then, unclear whether this translates
to clinical significance
because studies that have looked
at zinc replacement are old
and they're all from the
eighties and nineties
and have not shown a huge difference,
but increased prevalence
of zinc deficiency
may have something to do with increased
dermatologic issues as well.
Increased risk of autoimmunity,
which is well described in
individuals with Down Syndrome.
Obviously has an effect on the skin.
Some autoimmune diseases have
dermatologic manifestations,
this is dermatitis herpetiformis,
associated with celiac but
also thyroid disease, diabetes,
autoimmune hepatitis can
have skin representations.
And then some autoimmune diseases
directly affect the skin,
from vitiligo, to alopecia
areata, to psoriasis.
So from here on out,
I'm gonna take you
through a whirlwind tour
of skin conditions.
I have thirty minutes to
go over thirty slides,
so I will have to go quickly,
everything is in your handouts,
and I made the slides a bit busy
so you could refer to them in your handout
if you come up with any of these issues.
Starting with vascular lesions.
Pretty much all babies
will have some degree
of cutis marmorata, or livedo reticularis,
which are very, very similar conditions.
When dermatologist thinks of
livedo reticularis, they think
autoimmune, rheumatologic conditions.
But when it comes to
kids with Down Syndrome,
it actually doesn't seem to be
associated with vasculitides.
They're more prominently
seen in cold temperatures,
so whenever my nurses undress
the babies to weigh them,
you can see the cutis marmorata,
you can see some cutis and livedo
in the pictures above.
You don't have to refer cutis.
It will go away on its own,
it will probably take longer to go away
than most other babies
without Down Syndrome,
but it's not scary or dangerous.
Vascular malformation.
I couldn't find anything in the literature
that showed a clear increased
risk of vascular malformations
in individuals with Down Syndrome,
but what we do know is that
kids with Down Syndrome are
at increased risk of atresia
throughout the GI tract,
including anal atresia,
and anal atresia is associated
at times with vascular malformations
as part of bigger syndromes
such as PELVIS and SACRAL syndromes.
I love dermatology because
all their syndromes
make complete sense and have cute names.
So PELVIS stands for perineal hemangioma,
external genital malformations,
lipomyelomeningocele,
vesicorenal abnormalities,
imperforate anus, or a skin tag.
SACRAL is spinal dysraphism,
anogenital cutaneous renal,
and urologic anomalies,
and angiomas in the
lumbosacral localizations.
So this is an example of one patient with
this rash that would be paler,
and then become red, and
then become purplish,
and then disappear,
and this child that has anal atresia,
and also has a tethered cord,
and really fits the picture
for one of these syndromes.
And vesicoureteral reflux
it really fits the
picture for the syndrome.
Transient myeloproliferative disorder
is seen with increased
incidents with individuals
with Down Syndrome,
it's a transient aberrant proliferation,
of some cell lines.
Some kids need treatment,
for some kids it resolves on its own.
And then the more serious version,
congenital leukemia.
Both of these conditions
can be associated with
dermatologic manifestations.
Congenital leukemia is associated
with leukemia cutis,
which are these blue, firm
infiltrated papules and nodules,
and then for leukemoid reactions
and transient myeloproliferative disorder,
kids can have vesiculopustular eruptions,
such as the ones seen in this text book
or peer-reviewed article picture.
There should be a deferential, because
it could be, of course, Herpes, Staph,
congenital candidiasis,
however, a CBC might give you
a clue into what's going on,
because if you see a
whole lot of white cells,
then it's probably transient
myeloproliferative disorder
or congenital leukemia.
And it resolves with treatment,
the treatment is not geared at the rash,
the treatment is geared at
the blood cell dyscrasia.
Atopic dermatitis is common.
According to the literature,
about as common as it is
in the general population,
which is common.
Xerosis cutis, so dry skin, is so common.
Everybody gets it,
or almost everybody has dry skin,
I can ever generalize.
And it tends to get worse
with time and with age.
And certainly having dry skin
and a non-intact skin barrier
can pre-dispose you to
have irritant contact derm,
and allergic and contact dermatitis.
So gentle skin care needs to be emphasized
from the very beginning.
I won't use names or brands,
I'd just say, if you can smell the soap,
it's not good for you.
If you can smell the lotion,
And you know, we talked
about sensory issues.
But if you get used to this baby
being lubed up all day long
from when they're babies,
then it's just going to be
a part of their routine,
as opposed to if you tried to start
moisturizing a teenager
with sensory issues.
Eczema is also common,
and where I see it a lot is the cheeks,
so malar erythema is commonly seen
in kids with Down Syndrome,
especially in the winter.
Many of you are quite
familiar with treating eczema,
so gentle skin care, topical
steroids when indicated,
and managing the Staph colonization
that can worsen eczema.
Most eczema doesn't need to be referred,
if you get stuck and you cannot get
good results and you know that the family
is actually doing what they're supposed to
then you should refer,
but the cases that are
referred for atopic derm
are few for Down Syndrome, for me.
Cutaneous infections are common,
ranging from folliculitis to furuncles,
to abscesses to secondary
impetigo in someone with eczema.
A study, there's the same few studies
are referenced throughout this talk,
because there aren't that many people
who are looking at dermatologic issues
in individuals with Down Syndrome.
I want to note that some of these studies
were done in institutionalized patients,
so we have to keep that in mind
when thinking about
our sample size and the
factors of living in an institution
that could affect the skin.
But Schepis et al found folliculitis
to be the most common dermatologic
condition in their studied population.
It was a mix of bacterial folliculitis,
which is very common in the
gluteal and perineal region,
as well as pityrosporum
folliculitis which is
often seen in adults with Down Syndrome,
in the chest and infrascapular region.
How do we treat it?
If it's bacterial
we often use eradication measures,
so your diluted bleach bath,
topical antiseptics like Hibiclens wipes,
and then topical clindamycin gel
is often very effective at controlling
the bacterial folliculidities.
For pityrosporum, topical ketoconazole,
your Selsun Blue, basically.
But you know, you don't want to put
shampoo necessarily on the skin,
so you can also get two
percent ketoconazole lotion,
but you may need oral treatment.
And a single dose of
flucon is often enough
to eradicate pityrosporum.
So you don't really have
to refer folliculitis
unless it's refractory complicated.
Seb derm is super common,
and it has a bimodal age distribution.
Babies, but all babies have some,
or most babies have
some seb derm cradle cap
on the scalp and on the T-line.
Or the T-region.
And then later on, in older childhood,
often presenting as itchy dandruff.
Strong association with
pityrosporum folliculitis.
For babies, as Dr. Howard says,
who is it bothering?
The parent or the child, right?
So you can do mineral oil in a comb,
you may use hydrocortisone,
for older children ketoconazole,
two percent shampoo,
or Selsun Blue, can
control seb derm very well.
You don't have to refer it
unless it seems really hard to treat,
because the deferential
of seb derm in the scalp
is scalp psoriasis,
so if you don't get good
control with these measures,
then it might be psoriasis,
then it probably needs a
dermatologist's, input.
Keratodermatoses are very common as well.
Keratosis pilaris has a well known
association with Down Syndrome.
15 percent of individuals
with Down Syndrome
were found to have K.P in one study.
And what it is is the hair follicles
get plugged up with dead skin cells,
which creates this rough texture,
it often happens here and on the thighs.
And it can be itchy, and it can be dry.
The treatment is trying
to use non-soap cleansers
to allow the skin to retain its moisture,
but exfoliating the dead
skin cells can be helpful.
And then using moisturizing creams,
especially moisturizing
creams containing urea,
or salicylic acid, can be very
helpful in controlling K.P.
Palmoplantar hyperkeratosis
is also very common,
high prevalences in some studies.
I have to be honest, I
don't see as much of it
as what's quoted in the studies.
But it's well defined,
hyperkeratotic plaques
that are distributed at pressure points
of the palms and soles.
And the treatment is emollients
and keratolytic agents.
You can use topical retinoids
and topical vitamin D ointments,
such as calcipotriene.
These are things that
don't need to be referred
unless they're complicated refractory.
You know, a lot of
families come in saying,
I need a dermatologist referral,
and I feel very empowered to say,
okay, how about I try to treat the rash,
since there's a long wait
to see the dermatologist,
because there's few excellent
people like Dr. Howard,
and then if we get stuck, then no problem.
And it feels real good
to solve people's issues
without having to send them
to yet another specialist.
Periorificial dermatitis, I see it a lot.
They're periorificial
papules and pustules,
and they can start as
isolated papules and pustules
and can become more confluent.
And they're on the spectrum of rosacea.
So if you're familiar with rosacea,
you know that it can
flare and then go away,
and it might flare with
the time of day, with the temperature,
hopefully my kids are
not drinking alcohol,
but it can wax and wane.
Pre-disposing factors is
steroids around the area,
and how many of our kids
are on intra-nasal steroids,
or inhaled corticosteroids
if they have asthma.
So think of that mask,
a face there with mask, as an offender.
And then, to be frank,
sometimes you don't know what it is,
you think it might be eczema
so you're like,
let's put some steroids on this and--
(growls)
it gets really upset.
The treatment, topical antibiotic gels
like metronidazole gel
or a topical Clindagel
can be effective.
Sometimes it flares the rash
before it makes it go away,
which is hard for the family to see.
And you can use systemic treatments
like doxy cycling at acne
doses over a couple of weeks,
or Azithromycin at pneumonia dosing,
and it will melt the rash away.
If it fails the first line treatments,
you should refer for further guidance.
Certainly some of these bother the parent
more than the kid,
but I definitely see a lot of kids
scratching and really
bothered by the rash,
so that's something that I like to treat.
Especially if I see excoriation marks.
This, I find very interesting.
It's not that there's
higher concentration of calcium in the
sweat channels of people
with Down Syndrome,
which might lead to
sweat duct calcification,
which leads to these
milia-like calcinosis cutis,
which are these small,
discreet white papules
that look like milia but are more firm
and like look chalky, like
there's calcium in there.
Usually, they're asymptomatic,
they're not bothering anyone,
someone might think they're a wart
and get real freaked out by it.
But otherwise, they're
not that bothersome.
And no treatment is necessary
unless they're painful
and if they're painful
they can be curetted.
And they shouldn't be
confused with milia milia,
like those seen in under the eye
in the picture below.
But either way, you're
not gonna do much about it
other than re-assure.
Syringomas are similar to milia,
but they're small, flesh colored,
yellow-brown dermal papules.
And in our individuals with Down Syndrome
are very often seen in the eyelid
and that's actually much,
much, much more common
to be seen under the eyelids
than in the general population.
There's a female pre-dominance,
as reported in this very
recent study from 1964,
and there's an association with
the milia-like calinosis cutis,
so wondering if it's some sort of similar
pathogenesis to it.
They're not easy to treat,
and they don't bother
anybody other than the child
if they don't like how they look,
or the parent if they
don't like how they look.
So I would say refer
only if the kid is bothered by it.
Because it the kid is bothered by it
then we should treat it, right?
If someone is having self
esteem and image issues
related to these,
then, you know, just like
we would for anybody else,
we should refer,
but if nobody else
cares, then leave him be,
because the treatment is
electrocoagulation, cryotherapy.
And neither of those feel great.
Vitiligo consists of de-pigmented,
generally well demarcated areas.
Not hypo pigmented areas.
So it's not just lighter than the skin,
it's like, white.
The estimated prevalence is two percent,
as opposed to one percent
of the general population.
There is an association
with hypothyroidism,
so I do check TSH and free T4 and
even the antibodies.
And kids will come in with vitiligo
as well as alopecia areata.
They will light up brightly
under Wood's light,
as shown in this picture.
And in terms of treatment,
it's difficult to treat.
You can start with topical steroids,
like 0.1 percent triamcinolone.
Maybe even lidex, and
then you might need to add
a topical tacrolimus,
and then light therapy is very effective,
but talk to Dr. Howard for two minutes
to get to hear what light therapy access
is like in our area.
Non existent.
Sorry, I spoiled it.
This is something that should be referred,
because we're talking
about big gun steroids,
big gun immunosuppressants,
like tacrolimus.
The focus of treatment
is generally more on the
face than on the body,
and I think that part of
the focus of treatment
is also acceptance.
And positive body image type messaging,
because it is hard to treat,
and it's unlikely that
we'll be able to make
all these spots go away.
So feeling comfortable
with them is important.
And then some people use makeup
to cover them up if they're
not comfortable with them.
There's famous models with vitiligo.
If you want to look at awesome pictures,
look up Positive Exposure
by Rick Guidotti,
a famous fashion photographer
who decided to start photographing
individuals with all
different genetic conditions
in a way that's respectful,
as opposed to the textbook pictures
with the eyes blocked
and the genitals visible.
Alopecia areata is also more prevalent
in individuals with Down Syndrome
than in the general population.
There's a possible female predominance.
Again, there's an association between
genes that live on the 21st chromosome
and alopecia, specifically MxA,
the product of MX1 gene,
which is an interferon inducible protein,
that is strongly expressed in
the lesional anagen hair-bulbs
from patients with alopecia areata.
It is associated with vitiligo,
thyroiditis, hypothyroidism,
trachyonychia.
So again, if I see it,
I check thyroid levels
and thyroid antibodies.
It tends to be more severe
in individuals with Down
Syndrome and harder to treat.
Topical steroids are the first line,
but you should refer.
I don't think you should hold off
on starting topical steroids as you refer,
because I told you to start.
Because Dr. Howard told you to start.
But do refer, because again,
this is hard to treat.
The next three things I'm gonna talk about
are related to weight,
which takes me on a tangent.
Please do not use the Down
Syndrome growth curves
to evaluate for obesity in
individuals with Down Syndrome.
Growth curves are normative
curves, like, you know,
take the bell curve and
turn it into curves.
So if there's a condition that's prevalent
in fifty percent of the population,
then what will look 50th percentile
and average on that growth curve
is actually gonna be obesity
and you're gonna miss obesity.
So please, please, please,
use the CDC growth curves when evaluating
weight and BMI for individuals
with Down Syndrome.
Newer studies from Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia
suggests that the 85th percentile for BMI
in individuals with Down
Syndrome actually represents
obesity, based on different
fat distributions.
Acanthosis Nigracans starts as
flat hyperpigmentation,
and then becomes velvety.
It's often seen in the back of the neck,
also in the armpits.
Many patients think that the kid is dirty,
and really it's a skin change.
It's associated with insulin resistance,
and we have to think about that
because the incidence
of diabetes mellitus,
both type one and type two,
is higher in our patient population
of individuals with Down Syndrome.
There's a really high prevalence
of being overweight and
obesity, as I just said.
And then newer studies are showing
that actually an extra copy
of the DSCR1-4 gene
from the 21st chromosome
actually leads to
dysregulated hepatic glucose
homeostasis and pyruvate intolerance,
which is likely what explains
the higher incidence of non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease
in our individuals with Down Syndrome,
so I am strict about sugar.
At our parties, there's
no juice, there's no soda,
there's just water.
And I talk to everybody
about limiting sugar intake
and not rewarding with food.
Because of these issues.
You don't have to refer
to dermatology for acanthosis,
but maybe consider referring to nutrition,
consider referring to endocrinology.
I follow a skinny-mini
who's had acanthosis
for a couple of years
and I'm watching her A1C rise
and I think she's gonna reveal herself
as a type one diabetic soon.
Hidradenitis is another condition
that's made worse by
being overweight or obese.
They're inflammatory pustules, nodules,
and abscesses
that are often seen in
the armpits, the groin,
and sometimes the inframammary region.
And they are not infections, per se,
they're not the boil that you lance
and then you solve the infection.
They are related to an
inflammatory reaction
to bacterial skin colonization,
so we can not take the blame
completely away from Staph,
but unfortunately
you won't be able to treat it forever
just by lancing them
or giving antibiotics.
And if not treated promptly,
they'll lead to fistulous tracts,
and become much, much harder to treat.
The incidents in individuals
with Down Syndrome
is higher than in the general population,
and we do have a UCSF study going on
right now on hidradenitis.
The age of offset is younger.
Hidradenitis has a clear
female predominance
in the general population.
I have not seen studies
specific to Down Syndrome,
but again, because there's
a genetic underpinning,
I suspect that that female predominance
might not be quite as marked.
Treatment, part of it is
weight loss, because again,
this is exacerbated by
being overweight or obese.
Topical cleanser, diluted bleach baths,
the skin colonization
measures, are important.
You can start with topical
clinda for mild disease,
and see if that words.
Systemic treatment with, like,
taking doxycycline or
clindamycin all the time
might be needed to control.
These antibiotics both
control the bacteria,
but also have, on their own right,
anti-inflammatory properties
that help control hidradenitis.
If that fails, you might need to use
a combination of rifampin and clindamycin.
Oh, my goodness.
And then really, really
good results with Humira.
And at a recent talk
that Dr. Nicole Kittler,
one of the new UCSF dermatologists
gave at our Grand Rounds in Oakland,
she actually recommended
referring early for dermatology,
because I think sometimes
we beat around the bush
and let this get out of control,
when this could've been
ameliorated a lot earlier
with immunologic treatment.
I have a patient with hidradenitis,
and we tried the wipes,
wouldn't tolerate them.
Tried topical, wouldn't tolerate them.
Tried antibiotics, wouldn't tolerate them.
And I was like, you know, mom,
I think that we might
need to go to injections,
and I was floored, she was like,
please give me injections,
I don't want to fight
with him all the time,
just once a week is so much better.
Also, forget your biases,
because parents might feel
very differently from you
about escalating treatment.
Psoriasis also has an
association with weight.
Psoriasis is a chronic
inflammatory skin condition,
characterized by clearly
defined, red scaly plaques,
with the Auspitz sign
where it like, it bleeds
if you scratch it, right?
Okay.
And you should look for
it in the scalp as well.
Actually that's where I see it the most.
I don't have as many patients who have
scalp psoriasis elsewhere,
the majority of my patients
have it on their scalp.
And if it's just on the scalp,
keeping the hair short and
using things like tar gel and
ketoconazole shampoo can control it often,
sometimes we do have to
use topical steroid lotions
as well on the scalp,
but keeping the hair short,
especially for the males,
and those other two measures
are quite effective.
If it's on the skin,
then the treatment is more intensive.
It involves a high
potency topical steroids,
vitamin D ointments, Dr. Howard
will talk more about that.
And the deferential includes seb derm,
crusted scabies, other things.
But this is something you should refer.
Doesn't mean you can't start treatment,
especially if you have
a wonderful dermatologist like Dr. Howard,
who will answer you at all
times of the day and night,
but this is something
that should be followed
by a dermatologist.
A word on oral manifestations.
Macroglossia, sometimes
kids have a big tongue,
and sometimes the tongue just looks big
because the oral cavity is small.
The tongue can be fissured,
it can be geographic and
this is super common,
and it's not scary, and I just reassure.
Lip fissures and a lot
of angular cheilitis,
I think that has something to do
with that impaired killing,
fungal killing on the skin.
It's quite common,
and the treatment is some
topical lotrimin at first,
and then you can add a
little hydrocortisone.
After a couple of weeks.
You don't want to put steroids right away
on something that's thought to be fungal,
otherwise the fungus
is gonna throw a party.
You don't have to refer
unless the cheilitis develops
some sort of granuloma,
because of picking or touching
or excessive inflammation.
A word about institutionalization
in dermatology.
When you read these articles
about dermatology in Down Syndrome,
it talks about high rates of
onychomycosis, and scabies,
and the question is, well,
is it truly because of an inherent thing
with Down Syndrome?
Or is it because you studied patients
in an institutionalized setting
where things like scabies
can spread like wildfire?
What we do know about scabies
is that individuals with Down Syndrome
are more likely to have a crusted scabies
type of presentation,
and one of the thoughts is that maybe
they feel the itching a little bit less
due to the differences
in sensory perception and processing.
And that could lead to more
wide spreading of the scabies mite.
I did it.
So thank you for your attention,
and we'll answer questions together
after Dr. Howard's talk.